HE TAKES OVER FROM HERE.
HEY, SEAN.
>> Sean: BUCKLE UP, THE
PRESIDENT SET TO STAGE THE
STAGE ANY MOMENT NOW IN
PHOENIX, ARIZONA.
WE WILL TAKE YOU THERE LIVE
AS IT HAPPENS.
FIRST, WE START WITH THE
PRESIDENT WELL BLASTING MINI
MIKE THE FARMER BLOOMBERG
FROM EARLIER TODAY PROBABLY
A PREVIEW OF COMING
ATTRACTIONS FOR TONIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS MEETING, KEVIN WAS
JUST SAYING, WAS SET UP LONG
BEFORE DEVIN AND KEVIN SET
IT UP, LONG BEFORE WE HEARD
THAT MINI MIKE HATES THE
FARMER.
LONG BEFORE WE LEARNED ABOUT
HIS HATRED OF THE FARMER
DISRESPECT OF THE FARMER.
I DON’T KNOW.
I DON’T THINK HE IS GOING TO
BE THE CANDIDATE ANYWAY.
AMERICA IS A NATION BUILT BY
FARMERS WHO WORK HARD TO
PROVIDE THEIR FAMILIES,
SUPPORT THEIR NATIONS AND
DRAW OUT GOD’S ABUNDANCE
FROM THE EARTH.
YOU POUR OUT YOUR SWEAT AND
SOUL.
YOU POUR OUT YOUR HEART.
YOU REALLY DO.
YOU ARE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
YOU WORK SO HARD.
AND YOU ARE SMART AS HELL.
I WILL ALWAYS KEEP FIGHTING
FOR THE AMERICAN FARMER AND
RANCHER, THE PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM ARE GOING TO FIGHT FOR
YOU AND WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
AND WE ARE GOING TO GET YOU
YOUR WATER AND PUT A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON YOUR GOVERNOR
AND FRANKLY, IF HE DOESN’T
DO IT, YOU ARE GOING TO GET
A NEW GOVERNOR.
>> Sean: WE ALL NEED TO
THANK OUR FARMERS, THE HARD
WORK THEY DO.
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF SKILL,
ADVANCED DEGREES IN MANY
CASES.
THAT’S PROBABLY A PREVIEW OF
WHAT’S COMING UP IN JUST
MOMENTS.
WE WILL HAVE IT WHEN IT
HAPPENS LIVE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL, I’M
SURE, BE ADDRESSING MINI
MIKE THE FARMER BLOOMBERG.
WE WILL HAVE IT LIVE THIS
HOUR.
AND AS PER USUAL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS STARTED LINING UP
WELL OVER 24 HOURS AGO.
SOME EVEN CAMPING OUT
OVERNIGHT TO GET A SPOT
INSIDE.
WE’RE GOING TO CHECK ON
PHOENIX COMING UP THROUGHOUT
THE HOUR.
WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE, BY THE
WAY, HANNITY INVESTIGATION
AS IT RELATES TO, YEAH, MINI
MIKE THE FARMER, BLOOMBERG
AND HIS CRAZY POINTS OF
VIEW.
OUR OWN LAWRENCE JONES IS IN
VEGAS TONIGHT WHERE HE IS
ASKING DEMOCRATS WHAT THEY
REALLY THINK ABOUT THIS WEAK
FIELD AND THE CHAOS THAT HAS
BROKEN OUT IN THE PRIMARY.
BUT, FIRST, IT’S TIME FOR A
QUICK ROUNDUP OF ALL OF THE
OUT-OF-TOUCH DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES THAT WANT TO BE
YOUR NEXT PRESIDENT.
THE CLEAR FRONTRUNNER IS
BERNIE SANDERS, AVOWED
SOCIALIST EVEN HONEYMOONING
IN THE FORMER SOVIET UNION
HE NOW HAS A DOUBLE DIGITAL
LEAD IN THE REAL CLEAR
POLITICS NATIONAL AVERAGE
LIKE ANY GOOD SOVIET STYLE
SOCIALIST HE IS KEEPING SOME
PRETTY BIG SECRETS.
AFTER JUST A FEW MONTHS
AFTER THE 78-YEAR-OLD
SENATOR SUFFERED A MASSIVE
HEART ATTACK ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL HE IS NOW REFUSING TO
RELEASE ANY OF HIS MEDICAL
RECORDS.
ANY MORE THAT IS.
AND ACCORDING TO BERNIE IT
SHOULDN’T MATTER.
BECAUSE VOTING FOR HIM IS
LIKE VOTING FOR NELSON
MANDELA.
YOU HEARD ME RIGHT.
YOU CAN’T EVEN MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I’M THINKING BACK SOME OF
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH
NELSON MANDELA.
>> YES.
>> REMEMBER THAT AND HIS
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM IN SOUTH
AFRICA?
>> YES.
>> AND PEOPLE MARCHING TO
THE POLLS AND THINKING ABOUT
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
AND PEOPLE MARCHING TO THE
POLLS?
WELL, WE ARE FIGHTING TO
CHANGE AMERICA.
LET’S GO OUT.
I THINK THE POLLING BOOTHS
ARE PRETTY CLOSE TO HERE.
UNION BUILDING.
ALL RIGHT.
LET’S TAKE A LITTLE WALK.
LET GO.
LET’S CHANGE AMERICA.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: REALLY BERNIE,
NELSON MANDELA, SOCIALIST
UTOPIA MEANING YOURS; BERNIE
SOVIET ERA POLICIES UNTOLD
DAMAGE TO THIS COUNTRY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ONCE TO
NATIONALIZE THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY.
NATIONALIZE THE HEALTHCARE
BY THE WAY CONFISCATION OF
PRIVATE BUSINESS, PRIVATE
PROPERTY, MASSIVE, HUGE TAX
INCREASES FOR ALL AMERICANS.
EVEN CAPPING THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY YOU CAN MAKE AND, OF
COURSE, MEDICARE FOR ALL,
WHICH WE CAN’T AFFORD, HE
WILL DESTROY THE SINGLE BEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
FRANKLY IT’S KIND OF SCARY.
THIS RADICAL CANDIDATE COULD
VERY WELL BE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
FRANKLY THEY ALL SCARE ME.
AND WHILE BERNIE SANDERS,
THE BULL VIC HAS DECLARED
WAR ON FREE MARKET
CAPITALISM ONE OF HIS
CHALLENGERS MAYOR PETE
BUTTIGIEG ATTACKING
CHRISTIANS ALL OVER AMERICA.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO BE A CHRISTIAN
AND SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> WELL, I’M NOT GOING TO
TELL OTHER CHRISTIANS HOW TO
BE CHRISTIANS.
BUT, I WILL SAY I CANNOT
FIND ANY COMPATIBILITY
BETWEEN THE WAY THIS
PRESIDENT CONDUCTS HIMSELF
AND ANYTHING THAT I FIND IN
SCRIPTURE.
NOW, I GUESS THAT’S MY
INTERPRETATION.
[APPLAUSE]
BUT I THINK THAT’S A LOT OF
PEOPLE’S INTERPRETATION AND
THAT INTERPRETATION DESERVES
A VOICE.
>> Sean: OKAY.
YOU ARE A CHRISTIAN AND
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP.
IT LOOKS LIKE MAYOR PETE IS
LOOKING DOWN ON YOU AND TO
THINK, YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE
AS A SINNER.
I PLEAD GUILTY SINNER RIGHT
HERE.
ALL RIGHT?
WE SEEK OUT OUR GOD AND
JESUS, WHY?
TO CHANGE OUR HEARTS, TO
MAKE US BETTER PEOPLE, FOR
JESUS TO FORGIVE US OUR
SINS, OUR IMPERFECTIONS AND
DELIVER US FROM EVIL
WHATEVER OUR SINS HAPPEN TO
BE AS AN INDIVIDUAL HE CAME
AND GAVE HIS LIFE SO WE ALL
CAN LIVE, ALL OF US, BUT
CLEARLY THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT WILL NOW QUESTION YOUR
FAITH, OUR FAITH BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES?
WELL, THAT’S TAKING TRUMP
DERANGEMENT TO A WHOLE NEW
LEVEL.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
I GUESS ANOTHER DEMOCRAT
THAT THINKS WE, THE PEOPLE,
IR REDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES
SMELLY WATERMAN WALMART SHOPPERS
CLING TO OUR BIBLES AND
RELIGION.
HE DOESN’T CARE IF WE LOSE
OUR HEALTH INSURANCE BECAUSE
HIS SOCIALIZED MEDICARE FOR
ALL WILL TAKE CARE OF
EVERYBODY.
JUST TRUST MAYOR PETE, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
BY THE WAY DO NOT LIKE MY
PLAN THEY ATTACKED IT THE
MOMENT IT CAME OUT.
THEY DON’T WANT THE
COMPETITION.
THE QUESTION WHETHER IT
LEAVES PRIVATE INSURANCE
INTACT, THAT’S ACTUALLY UP
TO THE INSURANCE COMPANIES.
EITHER THEY WILL COME UP
WITH SOMETHING BETTER THAT
WILL COMPETE WITH THE PLAN
I’M PUTTING OUT THERE OR
THEY WILL FAIL.
AND TO BE HONEST, I DON’T
CARE.
>> Sean: I DON’T CARE IF YOU
LOSE YOUR HEALTHCARE.
THAT’S THE CANDIDATE THAT
THINKS THE DEMOCRAT --
ACTUALLY THINK HE IS A
MODERATE.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS NOW
DEVOLVED INTO ONE BIG
RADICAL SOCIALIST
ORGANIZATION.
AND PERHAPS MAYOR PETE
SELF-IMPORTANT ARROGANT
HOLIER THAN THOU ATTITUDE
ONE REASON IS HE STRUGGLING
TO GARNER SUPPORT FROM
ANYONE WHO APPARENTLY IS NOT
IN HIS DEMOGRAPHIC.
THAT’S NOT STOPPING HIS
CAMPAIGN FROM PRETENDING OH,
PRETENDING NOW HAVE MINORITY
SUPPORT THEY DON’T HAVE.
ABC NEWS REPORT MAYOR PETE
CAUGHT ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
BOASTING ABOUT ENDORSEMENTS
FROM AFRICAN-AMERICAN
LEADERS THAT HIS CAMPAIGN
NEVER RECEIVED.
WHOOPS?
BY THE WAY, WHAT DOES THE
BIBLE SAY ABOUT THAT NOW
THAT WE ARE QUOTING THE
BIBLE?
YOU SHALL KNOW THE TRUTH AND
THE TRUTH SHALL SET YOU
FREE.
NATURALLY NOT THE ONLY
DEMOCRAT TRYING SO HARD TO
PANDER FOR VOTES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
PAINFULLY BIZARRE AWKWARD
MOMENT.
IN THIS CASE IT’S AMY
KLOBUCHAR.
>> SO, LET ME TELL YOU FIRST
ABOUT ME.
MY NAME IS AMY.
AND WHEN I WAS -- TOOK
SPANISH IN FOURTH GRADE, MY
NAME WAS ALAYNA.
THEY GAVE ME THE NAME ALAYNA
BECAUSE I COULDN’T ROLL MY
R’S VERY WELL.
SO IT WAS ELENA.
>> Sean: KLOBUCHAR’S CRINGE
WORTHY CAMPAIGN MIGHT MAKE
YOU WANT TO CRAWL OUT OF
YOUR SKIN PAILS IN
COMPARISON TO SOME OF THE
RHETORIC COMING FROM
AMERICA’S GREAT FARMER WITH
A LOT OF GRAY MATTER.
THAT WOULD BE MINI MIKE
BLOOMBERG.
EVERY TIME HE OPENS HIS
MOUTH?
WHAT DO WE GET SOMETHING
ELITIST, ARROGANT AND BEYOND
OFFENSIVE COMING OUT.
REPORTEDLY MAKING DOZENS OF
CRUDE ANALOGIES BETWEEN
SALES AND HAVING SEX WITH
WOMEN ACCORDING TO VARIOUS
LAWSUITS.
I WISH I COULD SAY THIS
STUFF ON THE AIR IF I DID I
WOULD HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IT -- MANAGEMENT WOULD BE
MAD FOR A WHILE.
ALLEGEDLY HAS A NASTY HABIT
OF SCREAMING AT HIS
EMPLOYEES ESPECIALLY
PREGNANT WOMEN.
ONE WOMAN CLAIMING HE
ENCOURAGED HER TO GET AN
ABORTION TELLING HER TO KILL
IT.
THAT’S NOT ALL.
HE ONCE SAID THAT BLACK AND
LATINO EMPLOYEES DON’T KNOW
HOW TO BEHAVE IN THE
WORKPLACE.
AND HE SAID, OF COURSE, THAT
ALL THE CRIME, NOT SOME, ALL
THE CRIME IS HAPPENING IN
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THAT ALL CRIMINALS FIT
ONE M.O.
MINORITIES 16 TO 25.
ACCORDING TO BLOOMBERG YOU
JUST TAKE THAT DESCRIPTION,
XEROX IT, AND PASS IT OUT TO
ALL THE COPS.
AND IN 2011, BLOOMBERG ALSO
DELIVERED SOME SHOCKING
REMARKS DIRECTED AT AMERICAN
SENIORS.
ACTUALLY CALLED FOR
HEALTHCARE RATIONING FOR THE
ELDERLY.
AND THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
SHOULD TELL A 96-YEAR-OLD
WITH CANCER, QUOTE:  HAVE A
NICE DAY.
YOU HAVE LIVED A LONG LIFE.
THERE IS NO CURE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING FOR YOU.
PRETTY MUCH OF THE GO HOME
AND DIE APPROACH TO
HEALTHCARE OF OH, THE
BILLIONAIRE.
SO WHAT IF A PERSON IS 86,
FARMER MIKE?
OR 76?
WHERE IS FARMER MIKE’S
MEDICARE RATIONING BEGIN?
AND AT WHAT AGE DO THESE
DEATH PANELS OF HIS KICK IN?
FARMER MIKE, WE ARE LOOKING
FOR ANSWERS.
I DON’T QUITE HAVE THE GRAY
MATTER THAT ALLOWS ME TO
COMPREHEND YOUR PRETTY SICK
AND CALLUS GENIUS.
LET’S NOT ALSO FORGET FARMER
MIKE’S ALOOF COMMENTS ABOUT
AMERICA’S GREAT FARMERS.
HE SAID I CAN TEACH ANYONE
TO BE A FARMER.
HE CAN TEACH ANYBODY AT ALL
YOU JUST DIG A HOLE AND PUT
SEAT SEED IN IT AND PUT DIRT
ON TOP OF THAT AND ADD WATER
AND UP COMES YOUR CORN.
I DIDN’T KNOW IT WAS THAT
EASY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE SOCIETY LASTED 3,000
YEARS.
AND WE COULD TEACH
PROCESSES.
I COULD TEACH ANYBODY, EVEN
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM, NO
OFFENSE INTENDED, TO BE A
FARMER.
IT’S A PROCESS SEE.
YOU DIG A HOLE AND PUT A
SEED IN AND PUT DIRT ON TOP
AND WATER AND UP COMES CORN.
THE INFORMATIONAL ECONOMY IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT.
IT’S BUILT AROUND REPLACING
PEOPLE WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
THE SKILL SETS THAT YOU HAVE
TO LEARN ARE HOW TO THINK
AND ANALYZE AND THAT IS A
WHOLE DEGREE LEVEL
DIFFERENT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
SKILL SET.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LOT MORE
GRAY MATTER.
>> Sean: A LOT MORE GRAY
MATTER.
NOT LIKE THE FARMERS.
I CAN TEACH ANYBODY TO FARM.
AND IT GETS RIGHT TO THE
HEART OF WHAT ARROGANT
ELITIST POLITICIANS THINK
ABOUT WE, THE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST FARMERS
IN THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
THEY FEED US AND THE WORLD.
WE POINTED OUT LAST NIGHT
OUR GREAT AMERICAN FARMERS
THEY WORK AT INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX NEW, AGRICULTURAL
TECHNOLOGY, SOPHISTICATED
INDUSTRY.
I MEAN, THEY GET ADVANCED
DEGREES FROM SOME OF THE
MOST PRESTIGIOUS PROGRAMS
ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
AND IT’S BECAUSE OF THAT
GRAY MATTER AND INGENUITY
AND TIRELESS WORK THEY FEED